hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
this first game that we're gonna be
playing is called alien blackout and yes
this is the next game after alien
isolation that awesome aliens game where
you are exploring the derelict Space
Station with aliens investing every
corner of it and it was terrifying and
it was awesome also this video is
sponsored by alien blackouts publisher
d3 go but this is a mobile game which is
an odd choice but I'm not gonna let that
get me down I'm gonna give this the
benefit of the doubt and I'm going to
play this and I'm gonna give my
objective opinion on it and see if it's
actually scary because if it's scary if
it's fun at the end of the day that's
what really matters so let's do this
engineering Bay okay classic I like it
very pretty is Amanda Ripley Hey urgent
extraction from the mental research
station
if you pick up the signal perceive with
extreme caution
there's an alien organism or Luisana
station it is deadly
repeat deadly
it is that's the same person it is the
successor to that game I knew it so this
is Ripley from the movies daughter for
those of you don't remember I'll put a
link in the description to my
playthrough of alien isolation great
game if you haven't seen that game it is
an amazing game if you haven't played
that game it is an amazing game hello
just some diagnostic welcome to Mandal I
don't know what Mendel is his mental
something that I need to s class
commercial shuttle weyland-yutani was it
ever confirmed if was it ever confirmed
if Blade Runner and the alien movies are
in the same universe I think that was
confirmed wasn't it because the
replicants are all the same yes it was
because I was of course it was the day
yeah it was oh [ __ ] oh hi do I touch
that no it's like a five nights at
Freddy's hello
hi oh oh okay yes finally what this is
Amanda Ripley can you hear me hi oh no
you're all in danger
oh that's yes a problem
oh well it's easy is that okay well then
didn't you get my transmission this
place is a deathtrap okay we got
ourselves a deal close by
you should find sayers there I'm opening
the door now am i I don't know if that's
a good idea
oh [ __ ] oh my god uh am i those doors
this door control room I don't know what
I'm doing I have no idea what what what
am i doing engineering bed corridor - oh
I was - uh no my craft oh yeah I'm
afraid we're also on the clock here
banks are trigger-happy security the
grid was damaged I've wired up some
solar panels but their output is limited
only good for eight minutes before they
shut down to charge what do we do take a
left to that control room then bypass
the lock down and get to engineering
[Music]
okay you are it's just me now I'm in the
ducts using a maintenance access point
the pots were yeah prematurely some may
have made it I don't really know
yeah but nominee or should opener
careful now it's
an alien organism it lives to kill sighs
devastated by a single entity seems
unlikely yeah well you know how it is
work but don't underestimate this thing
I've seen it do worse uh-huh I've
encountered these creatures before and
I'm still having nightmares ever hear of
sevastopol station oh yeah didn't I do
that wasn't I supposed to do that or did
the whole thing get shut down because
they were trying to prevent alien
encroachment either way bad news all
around I don't quite actually remember
what the story was all I know is you
were running away a whole lot I don't
remember the actual objectives that I
was doing okay so you're in there what
is that's what I'm doing baby I don't
know why or what I'm supposed to be
doing but I'm watching over you leg hawk
well I don't know what to tell you we
can track them down all the service
orders can be accessed from the
administrative hub there's a door right
next to the docking lounge but the
others should return to the shuttle
first it
[Music]
why yeah that's a problem is it coming
for me
wait me oh no wait oh that was that was
not a part of the deal tapping yeah Moe
good it'll come back soon I'm trying to
keep fix on it with the cameras and the
motion trackers motion for this small
portable unit hooked up to an access
point what are you doing oh go there
no don't rely on me guiding you all the
time
that creature tracks human voices and
those really travel in the ducts also no
running if you can avoid it
where are me no okay
sido stud week
maybe they should stick together maybe
that's a good thing right I don't know
what the green means I'm not sure what
the green means oh okay this is cool
this is honestly an interesting way to
do it it's kind of nice having an
overview of everything I wasn't sure at
first but I kind of get it okay so I
need to watch out for myself and watch
out for them guide them so that they
don't die and hopefully that means that
they're gonna get their objectives and
get out and I only have a certain amount
of time to do it until blackout hence
daylian blackout okay easy peasy then
they're not dead right there we go and
they're good right yes miss you Tony
why are you oh you guys are going boy
why why are you doing that okay what are
you doing wait wait wait
ah
go be your tani go there why Oh No okay
okay I think I get it
this is cool is cool the admin hub isn't
too far but I'll need to move to a new
access point
oh yeah once I'm connected again why do
I need to move the crew pulled me out of
a bad situation and brought me here
actually when I came out of high
perceived it but this one was born here
all right we can talk about it after
for now let's chatter yeah I agree with
that one why do I need to go to any
other place okay you and your new new
crew head to the administrative hub to
find where the scrubbers have been taken
okay great yeah that's good I'm happy
about that
that was the first level of it I'm gonna
[Music]
since I was 16
Thorncrown Croft yes can we proceed sure
the information will be on one of the
work associated with all due respect to
your credentials
we still need a crew ID for those
I have been in charge okay are you go
this way you split up that'll be more
efficient right perfect
you hurry up hurry hurry hurry
oh oh okay you got it buddy
[Music]
now for that work station craft
oh [ __ ] Oh
oh my god what what oh [ __ ] um oh oh
[ __ ]
ah go here
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] um oh oh [ __ ]
I can't control that creature I can only
track it oh boy wait so he's just dead
now but right now I'm the only bet you
have Oh No so keep it together and we'll
make it through this Oh No
well I didn't know their homes I didn't
know that that's that's out I didn't
know oh my god I didn't know I didn't I
did not know I really honestly truly did
not know Oh No oh wait what was that
no I didn't know is he all hands on deck
I didn't want him to die okay okay so I
just got a watch for where they could be
try to trap him in the area I didn't
know how to play the oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
um okay you're good so far right there
[Music]
hide hide hide okay it's going in there
that's fine
oh [ __ ] this is cooler than I thought
it'd be like honestly I didn't know how
mobile alien game would work but this is
cool this is really cool now [ __ ] it's
really really going for it oh wait
[Music]
uh which way you're going okay yeah go
that way yeah go that way yeah that's
the way you want to go okay okay okay
[ __ ] where is it then where did it go
would it have gone in the I guess it
might have gone in the vents that guess
cuz there's an access point up there on
the north side but that's about it I
don't know what else I mean the motion
tracker seemed to be my best bet hurry
up go for it just go for it why wouldn't
you go for it
not so fast okay maybe because it's not
gonna be game over once they get in
there I forgot about that
dammit I should have died I can't
believe he's dead oh [ __ ] I need to
switch access points again I'm sorry no
it shouldn't have happened I didn't know
that that was what I didn't know what do
you mean wait what yeah that's just in
flat I don't get another chance about
that he's just dead forever he's dead
he's dead okay he's just he's dead okay
um that's not what I was hoping for
really not what I was hoping for I was
really hoping that there was gonna be
something else
oh there it is it's at the far end of
the hall there we need to check if the
Train is there you'll have backups
to check out the platform first okay oh
[ __ ]
where did it go it was right there wait
oh [ __ ] Oh oh [ __ ] okay um close that
door
it's just right there but if the doors
closed it shouldn't know right where to
go
where'd it go where'd it go it went in
the ducts I guess that's as much safety
as I can give them but there's still the
dice Oh
[Music]
did I block it in no I didn't block it
in at all they might be dead I don't
know whole ships
oh [ __ ] Oh
lucky for us same backup loop is the
docking system okay alright what was
that what was happening you're going
there why are you going that way that's
the stupid way to go why would you go
that way that's a terribly horribly
stupid way to go oh [ __ ] I can't cover
him at all I have no idea where they are
I have no idea where they're going I
have no idea if there's gonna be
something waiting for it then who's that
mother hide then oh wow oh how would I
have known how how was I supposed to
know I couldn't I couldn't have known
oh honey hi where is he where is he
I don't know ooh there he is okay he
just vanishes off the face of the earth
okay you're just hiding in there right
for the best actually because there
seems to be hoho that's that's a problem
that's a problem yeah it's a problem oh
that's a problem oh yeah it's a big
problem oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay you
are not going that way no no no you
wouldn't want to go that way anyway
that'd be ridiculous can you hurry up
you Sonny
things are getting pretty dicey here I
don't really know what to do
the creature won't be drawn to the noise
oh [ __ ] what noise what noise we talking
about talking noise and me my noise I'm
not a noisy guy I don't think anyway
okay I got a yutani
oh my god I've got to use you Tony all
the way over there I don't know where
this thing is oh it's over there
okay you tani hurry up okay go go go oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] go this way go there oh oh
okay you're seeing him we waited to go
oh he's going that way okay good okay
all right that's good
no no no um okay you need to hide cuz I
don't know where he is or where he's
going uh Dee you gotta move okay you're
gonna sneak you're gonna come out where
are you I can't cover you from there
okay there okay it's up there that's
good to know
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no hide hide hide
Mike
hide hide hide hide hide oh oh well you
better just go then go for it come out
Jesus I am trying my best here it's not
working oh my god hurry up please
oh jeez Oh God okay just go for it oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] you made it the other end
you can just follow the signs to farm a
lab we need to keep moving I knew that
was blind corner but I didn't know where
it was gonna go alright so that was
alien black up that was really good
surprisingly good it is innovative in a
way that I've never played a game like
it before but I do like the overview
kind of look at it it's a little bit
like five nights at Freddy's
but more meticulous in that the cameras
you actually have a reason to check
around it kind of gives you a reason to
look out for this thing and it gives you
a reason to look out for the people that
are about to die from this thing and I
didn't know how to play in the beginning
and I didn't do so good but I got better
towards the end I just got missed like
this clicked here and there but that was
pretty good so if you want to play this
game for yourself open the link in the
description below it's five bucks
iOS Android there's no microtransactions
which is nice it was always nice to just
pay for a game and you get to play the
whole game and there's no pieces missing
so that's kinda nice so let's move on in
the next scary game let's go now this
one's called I'm lost which is so sad
but we got to get out of these woods
somehow it's another one of those games
where no doubt on your
he says that I recently fell in over
como two beats there's certain
possessions wrong on those rings again
which to track back into available with
that said Davy I'll just come earlier
say you have an incentive Momo you can't
use over the power on them in the past
Bailey all larner its announcer been
exhausting the only on comes less than
one point behind blow and Bailey or pull
the wall oh I'm so sorry but it's all
going to do we can give you some time to
decide I want to give you I know it's
not an easy decision
that was oddly timed that was Victor I
was I was a victim of unfortunate timing
right
ah beautiful so ah yeah great
oh I gotta move forward towards the
light cuz I'm dead cuz I hit a deer and
died and got impaled by the antlers also
my son is dying not good all around but
I guess this would explain why I'm lost
man this is a long tunnel to go to get
to the light at the end of the tunnel
hello
I can't sprint so this is as fast as I
can go right oh wow beautiful good stuff
oh well I'm not dead
well I came back from the death oh this
doesn't seem too good so I'm assuming
this is gonna be bad
oh hi hello what are you looking at huh
you ever seen a guy in a car accident
bleeding to death before you dad oh [ __ ]
oh no I skipped the light of the tunnel
that goes straight to hell
no what I'm lost I'm in purgatory I'm
gonna be here forever
Oh what is this this is a bad tunnel
this is the opposite of a light tunnel
this is no good this is no point oh this
is on good this is anti bueno is that a
leg oh hi
how you doing you statue you person okay
goodbye whoa I'm out okay well I guess
I'm done now stare too long in the
Statue never good for anybody uh-huh
uh-huh go on
oh [ __ ] and now I'm in the woods and
something else is in the woods too
that's always a good sign
I like that hello hi dad that sounds
good I like that sound that's a good
sound all right
oh or walking great where am I
where's my son I'm guessing if I'm not
there he just has to die a slow painful
death which is not good so can I get
back to my son so I could pull the plug
on him is this a road or is this just uh
the edge of the map that hasn't been
it's the edge of the map that hasn't
been developed yet okay well guess I'm
going back into the woods Oh yuck
was it you want to run that by me again
I didn't actually think you would I've
got no sense of direction no bearing no
sprint oh that is my sprint this is
sprint
I am sprinting who's that that's some
weird wolves out tonight
they're real demonic sounding you guys
are funny cool is this am i posting the
edge of the map that's not developed I
have no idea because I don't know where
I'm going there's no I - approach the
edge of the map that's undeveloped
because I don't know where I'm going
I'm just gonna assume I'm going towards
the sounds which isn't my bass instinct
that's not normally the back of my brain
is like don't cord go towards the
demonic sounds of death and destruction
also the demon goats and babies those no
good neither that's all my that's
everything that's just happening in the
background of my mind just screaming
that constantly I guess is living up to
its name I do indeed feel like I am lost
I am indeed lost but until something
actually jumps out of me I'm gonna
assume that's absolutely dick diddly
so come on do something if you want to
or too big of a baby then don't shoot
him
hello hey hey don't do that thing I told
you to do go do dick did Lee don't
did Lee dick I don't know pick one pick
whichever one toss the edge of the map
again I have no idea where I'm going I
feel like I'm going in a big circle I
feel like I'm being funneled into a
stupid circle because I'm just dumb and
I have no pathfinding ability and I
don't know what I'm doing I have been
walking for 30 minutes I found nothing
there is dick over there did leave there
I've been picking random directions now
because I'm pretty sure I've bumped up
against the entire perimeter this entire
island whatever it is without anything
happening so I'm just gonna try to go in
to the densest part of whatever woods
there may or may not be and hope for the
best
and don't touch the noises they're just
on a loop and there's no direction to
them so it's this defensive nothing oh
wait my ass out which way this way oh
look is there's another sign that I just
so happened to not see near oh it's okay
I'll get over it
it's all good baby it's all good it's
all good
hey it's the thing
hey how did I not find you wandering
randomly for 30 minute that's fine back
into it
my son dying I am dead a bucket of blood
always refreshing after a long walk what
we got here I've been stuck in my home
for the last five days though I know the
feeling on November the 16th I was
chosen by a humanoid creature roughly 5
foot 5 grace colored I'm gonna head out
of here soon to find food and water God
be with me numbers numbers numbers
numbers ok so what does that do for me
what am I supposed to do about [ __ ]
oh hi you know what you at nap time
my guess nappy mark he needs his nap nap
with my eyes open though Oh someone
Kirsten I can do that too what's going
on talk to me I feel like you're not
communicating enough oh hello ah that's
an annoying alarm it's all a dream one
receive Friday at 350 2 a.m.
I told you
[Music]
to replay this message press one to hear
next message press 2 to okay I guess
there's no reason to do that all right
well that just seems like everything in
this guy's life yeah I'll walk towards
that yeah I'm gonna walk towards that
yeah I'm gonna look real close to that
yeah come on bring it on you always you
got huh
help who who are you yes I'll help I'm
helpful
who's my Oh Joe what huh I couldn't hear
you you were whispering so I got closer
two weeks later nice nap I sure do love
my naps and stuck your longer than that
other guy oh I was just taking a piss go
to the kitchen I heard in my brain you
guys didn't see but I heard it oh that's
oh yeah yeah okay use that
ah these voices in my head maybe I
shouldn't listen to them
oh well place blood in the pentagram oh
good great
I can't move out of this place okay
guess I'm not done here oh don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't do it
you're gonna do it oh hey
what's that I can't hear you you're
whispering hello hi yes oh you're good
oh um I'm man
stranger danger no uh-uh I got a knife
oh boy all right fine I'll come to you
then
mission accomplished
I did it I'm the best better than there
ever was no oh man a dead end or my last
Wednesday
please wherever hole the scene of The
Nanny on that is I died heart murmur
it's unclear if it was suicide
overnight my blood what located in the
apartment but the managed almost
untouched SATs on small wound on my a.m.
we seized a body had been physical marks
rule out that he died himself on one
night night
no boys was located the man left behind
a son of Dorothy recovered evidence Bob
bought that data a noble founder who
explained how he would sell himself evil
to save 800 it all worked out then c'est
la vie everything's hunky Dicky here
that wasn't bad just a lack of clear
direction in polish like a lot of these
games that are just made either as a
first-time project or by very small
indie developers or someone who's like
not fully experienced not saying this
person that Felice perience with game
development but obviously it doesn't
have the polish of a full game it was
still not bad had a few jumps a few
scares a few Goods what do we need a
move on next game alright so this one's
called critters for sale and I gotta
admit the style of this one is really
impressive to me I like what it's got
going to snake monkey oh I'll go with
snake then I'll take a critter I'll take
a snake
I like snake snakes great who doesn't
love snake Oh click to begin my name is
Sergey
I'm 27 years old November 20 33
temperature is 23 degrees Celsius
critter snake
ah I don't like that
your phone's ringtone disrupts a good
night's sleep hey you take out your
phone to check the message you just
received yeah
Michael Michael Jackson a text from
Michael J Oh text for Michael Jackson
huh
all right meet me at 4 a.m. in the
limelight must be Chris and his lame
attempts at humor satisfy Michael
Jackson's requests [ __ ] I don't get out
of bed for less than Stevie Wonder huh
I'm not falling for this not at 3:00
a.m. in the morning later that night
it's comforting cold air in the room
interrupts your sleep you soon wake up
again ok Bob no thank you
what hey oh no thank you
you start thinking up being paralyzed
with a terrorizing figure next to yous
an indicator of sleep paralysis and that
if you could close your eyes this Oh
were those your hands oh no not my
supple neck however this doesn't seem to
be another episode of sleep paralysis
it's the end of these grip on your neck
feels very much real oh no dude the
perpetrator watching you die with a cold
gaze utters a few words that you know
will be your last third noid man you
can't hurry up wait you can't escape
wahoo
I I'm dead I'm dead real dad from the
noid man void I don't know look like
noid man I'm gonna go with noise man all
right back it because I guess what Oh
snake let's do this come on Oh baby okay
we're back into it still hate that so
note to self don't reject Michael
Jackson's invitation
never been to the limelight but it's
just around the corner so I should just
check what this is about at 3:00 a.m.
hahaha okay into the club a bit fat no
to that one oh oh it's like a point in
cloak wow what are you an innate
inclination to break this intricate
piece of art is settling in you huh yeah
oh yeah thank god that's a life I uh got
it he seems to be embedded in the
sculpture you decide not to take it take
it anyway okay that's probably fine I
love the style of this game go back sure
[Music]
good evening welcome to limelight how
may I be of help
ah I was invited to the nightclub by
someone calling themselves Michael
Jackson may I have your name sir yi
sergei volkov oh yes of course you
listed as a VIP guest VIP news day I
mean of course I should be one minute
mr. Sergei we will escort you to the
entrance of the club actually I'd like
to discover this place myself where will
I find the entrance only such treatment
for a VF years myself it's through that
door you see over there traverse the
corridor and you'll find the door
leading the lobby oh thank you thank you
very much I'll be on my way
don't mind the broken cat statue I'm a
VIP goodbye
clunk this door is locked funny about
that this doors locked
all right continue long oh I like the
smooth jazz this doors locked
this doors locked
and Daniel there we go Oh painting
depicting the Giza pyramid complex lose
yourself in its beauty of course I
didn't mean to I'm sorry I didn't want
to lose myself Allah I'm dead aren't I
oh I'm back yeah okay that wasn't good
cats okay
clunky out of your head her name is MIA
you don't know how you know but you do
yeah okay whatever you say Mia uh I like
this one
Oh log however the key withdrew from the
sculpture the receptionist desk seems to
be compatible attempt unlocking yeah of
course
screw you me I get out of here the door
has been unlocked thank you end of the
room
[Music]
okay well that was fun
so oh I don't like that ah I don't like
those annoyed men there's something I
don't like I'm gonna serve the highest
council usually in the sky this oh is
this an mp3 player push the trigger on
this remote when you're ready you're
gonna be so glad it was along on the
highlight
Jesus now it's time I read to go I'm
counting on you so long okay bye carpet
man all right let's push this button hey
I got places me I got people to see
let's go baby
push that button yeah of course
Bam Bam baby oh [ __ ]
did I do good that I did I feel like I
did good I feel like I did real girl ah
but I didn't want to serve the noid man
all right well then this game it's
really cool I'm gonna do one more I'm
gonna do a little more I just want to do
a little more I want to do a little more
it's really cool though I like this this
is this is good stuff now this is what I
call good stuff i swatched see what was
in the other door with the cat
good-evening blablablabla me I'm not
even gonna get the key I'm not even
gonna get the key cuz I don't want to
break the cat statue
yeah let's continue along yeah let's
keep going yeah I'm gonna keep going
whoa what do into the lobby sure the
lobby you say oh [ __ ] dude look at those
kicks look at that spread
look at that Brella oh this place is
bumping their legs were slender their
abdomens yellow making me believe there
were exotic bugs from somewhere exotic
you know right so me being Who I am I
decide to let them bite me for science
trust me those little [ __ ] those
little [ __ ] had the worst of all
bites the worst and so me being Who I am
the tough yet pain prone individual
can't take no [ __ ] from mosquito I
slapped the [ __ ] the mother
again and again me being me I picked the
mosquito pulp and savor it it actually
tasted good I [ __ ] you not the best I've
tasted as far as mosquitos go well
doesn't compare to the taste of a snake
but the tank sure had those exotic
undertones in it a beautiful night but
at what cost
good question long nose man what do you
think he has in that suitcase shut the
[ __ ] up man I told you to keep dancing
I'm telling you never brings a suitcase
so what could be his late-night snack in
there for all we know or it could mean
tonight is the night you know that's
what you want to hear I'm watching you
just blend in and keep dancing - this
isn't the type of music I'm used to and
it's not what teens these days
you either it's halfway between their
taste and mind if that makes sense first
the man with the suitcase
yes seems sooo who Michael Jackson Oh
don't like that don't like that at all
Oh Sergei you found your way here how
are you I'm I'm good
good such a beautiful night in this club
and with beautiful people in it too how
do you like the limelight yeah it's
mesmerizing clubs in general invoke the
claustrophobia in me and I feel that
absolute Asian air you know from the
outside it looks damn near impossible
for it to accommodate that long corridor
how much to walk Boz forgetting here
indeed it's a long walk before you reach
the inside but it's worth it the music
plays here is timeless excuse me for
asking but how do you know me I don't
think we've met before
remember what you and I share an
intimate friendship in the future you
haven't lived yet I don't understand you
and I will become friends in the future
and you somehow know that I don't just
know it I've seen it you have no idea
what you and I will go through and even
if I told you you wouldn't believe me
the most fascinating trips through space
and time the civilizations will meet and
the lives will change we're time
travelers Sergey I really don't think
I'm the person you believe I am are you
sure you're not somehow mistaken sergei
volkov a 27 year old taxi driver who
lives right around the corner isn't that
you are you Sergei no markiplier I
apologize but that's not me oh then oh
no wait no it took so long to get here
your head was split in half like a
pumpkin you think I can't see through
your [ __ ] Sergey if you don't want to
take part of this again then you can
[ __ ] off back to the grave well that did
reveal a little bit of truth happening
here okay weird all right weird all
right I'm gonna in this one here just
because I don't have the time in this
particular video to go through all the
options of this one and who knows how
far down that rabbit hole would have
gone so I'm just gonna leave this here
I'm gonna move on in the next game and
then we'll just call it even if you guys
want a place for yourself
in the description alright so this one
is something in the shadows it's
supposed to be a haunted house style
deal where am I
how did I get here I don't know do I
really need to get out
Oh notes collected okay alright hey how
you doing
oh ah behind you I don't believe you
didn't believe you
not for a second I'm a bit of an expert
at these horror games you think it's
gonna take that to startle me the answer
is no the answer is absolutely no you're
gonna do great deal more than just
simply that to get me the heebie and the
jeebies so don't even try it
hello hello comb hello note hello
anybody seen a newt new hello use the
front door I don't believe you again I
don't believe you I feel like that's a
trap I feel like I shouldn't trust the
weird notes that are strewn about my own
house then I wrote for all I know maybe
I'm a little crazy maybe I'm a little
forgetful maybe I'm a little bit of both
actually that's actually true ooh more
notes all right leave now
well I won't - it's locked I need to
find the key somewhere uh who knew it
wouldn't have been so easy so what do
you got for me now I get I know I know
how these goes now they move the spooks
are about to start a light bulb I wonder
at what I could use a pipe wonder I just
wonder a light bulb you say I have no
idea no lights
well but no not get that want that I've
been collecting notes why can't I get
that one what about that book Oh what
did I get
I didn't even read it I don't even read
it I didn't read it a bunch of baloney
all right basement noop I do love a good
basement though oh that's handy flash
bulb I can use the bulb I found still
needs some batteries I heard something
unlock upstair
that's not normal oh [ __ ] has that been
in all the paintings
all the paintings I didn't notice no no
way no no it has wait how did I how do I
miss that how did how did I miss that
ah good thing all these lights work it's
too late it's no use wherever you
whatever you say cuz some batteries are
some yeah alright okay
hello batteries anybody ooh
batteries ah right the flashlight works
did those doors downstairs just one lock
I definitely know the sound of that
happening from a great distance well I'm
headed down to inspect right now I know
what the dealio is that this oh you were
not there you weren't there mr. white
eyes
mr. glowy man you definitely hope you
weren't there don't look at me kid oh I
I don't like this now oh he's here who's
who's here got a key yeah the lights
turned off maybe there's a circuit
breaker oh is that me that's me that's
me that's me what why did that happen
why why'd that happen okay down in the
basement perfectly good great they blow
up the basement love that basement
worried about that whoa oh I don't like
that note that notes that no it's not
fun I don't know I don't like that no
okay circuit breaker okay there we have
it okie dokie where's that damn key good
question where is that damn key
okay I'm assuming this is gonna be an
easy going straight out the door
everything's fine I'm good and I get to
go home real quick right that's how
these things usually work for me I am a
bit of a badass Paul that was not there
that was not there I was so not there
that was a big lie wait my flashlight
doesn't work either my flashlight seems
to work just fine
whoa high on that one
the Bildner I'm a-comin now oh you were
right Hey hi are you doing hey is that
darker Blaire over there okay never mind
Oh fun great okay good I'm gonna leave
now
see ya my house yeah
hey I guess I didn't whoa
okay so that was something in the
shadows good atmosphere good potential
coulda used just a little more substance
to the scares but good nonetheless I
like that it had a lot of potential
opened up the door for a good haunted
house experiment could have used a few
more scares like even just a cliche jump
scare would have been nice at some point
but I did like the atmosphere not saying
it needed jump scares but needed
something more you know what I mean
anyway that is three scary games thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know if you got air games you want me
to play down the comments below
check out the other scare games that
I've played in the description a whole
playlist of them tons of them so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]